need an extra minute to just to kind of
double check your calculations but
um it does look like it's pretty
straightforward so far for aronian
black has a past pawn now white's given
up his extra two pawns actually
but white king is so active and
white's two pawns on that left flank at
least one of them is likely
to become a queen if not both i mean one
one thing i also have to say is that uh
lavon aronian isn't particularly scared
of blacks past pawn they're on the right
side and the reason why is because if
the worst comes to the worst
even if you were to give up your rook
for that pawn there are still
two past pawns that are very very
difficult for the black rook alone to
handle and i think that's gonna
well i don't think i believe that's
enough for it to be a win
so just magnus just resigns wow he
didn't even try to fight
uh his pawn was too slow he knows that
he's losing and magnus gives up
wow uh that is a shocking result in the
final game of today between levon
aronian and magnus crawls